the same the same discipline the same
practicalities apply to young parents
the sooner you start saving for your
call your child's college education the
less amount you have to save to achieve
your goal so the first thing a parent
needs to do is when they have their
child is apply for a Social Security
number and then consider opening up a
529 plan and a 529 plan allows you to
save up to actually up to a couple
hundred thousand dollars in one year if
you'd like but you can save in it you
know whatever amount you can save and
the 529 plan typically will invest in a
tart with similar to a target fund in
other words it will invest appropriately
in a mutual fund knowing that in 18
years you will need that money for
college and there's a lot of tax
benefits it grows tax-free and then when
you use it when your child's 18 and you
take withdraw for college there are no
taxes as well so it's a wonderful
benefit for parents because if you don't
have to pay taxes along the way your
money grows even faster and of course
and you know when you pay 18 years later
you're probably in a better financial
position and you get that tax benefit
you know you don't have to pay for for
the withdrawals and for the college
education
you